>> We often talk about classical and operant conditioning separately. However,
they can be used together to change behavior. A perfect example of this is the
story of Callie the sea lion. Let's go talk to Dr Zeligs about this. She can
tell us more.
>> Callie's back story is both heartbreaking and inspirational. So, she's the
youngest of my group, and she is, I believe, eight years old at this point. She
was one of the youngest surviving premature baby sea lions that has ever made
it. She was born more than one month premature. And her mother died of demolic
acid poisoning. Which is a type of toxic algae, it's a neuro toxin. Callie was
exposed to that toxin in utero, and has a huge range of neurologic and
gastrointestinal problems as a result of this exposure, so it's been touch and
go her whole life and one of her big problems is because of this really sort of
form of brain damage, she doesn't like food. So her natural instinct is to
starve herself and we have had to use classical conditioning actually to keep
her alive, because what she does like is behavior and people, because how she
was raised. So we used behavior and people to reward her for eating, which is
the opposite of what you normally think, but it's a great testimony to what
classical and operant conditioning can do, and today she's alive and healthy.
>> So learning saved her life.
>> [LAUGH]
Learning saved her life and, and she has learned to like fish.